شعب السودان العظيم ان قوات الدعم السريعه
الباسله مصممه وغادره على ملاحقه
الانقلابيين المستنفرين الذين يدقون طبول
الحرب اينما وجدوا في بلادنا بعد تسع اشهر
من الانتصارات العسكريه المتواصله وهزيمه
العدو في الخرطوم ودارفور وكردفان
والجزيره يجب عليهم الاقرار علنا بانهم قد
خسروا هذه الحرب وفشلوا فيها وعليهم
التوقف عن الاستنفار والقتال وتدمير
البلاد والتمهيد لانهاء الحرب ود عمليه
سياسيه انخرطنا في التفاوض منذ اليوم
الاول في منبر جده واكد موافقتنا
والتزامنا بمخرجات اجتماع رؤساء الايقاد
رؤيتنا ان هذه المفاوضات لا ينبغي لها ان
تدور حول اجنده او مجموعه بعينها وترتكز
على تحقيق مستقبل السودان ويجب ان تؤدي
الى حل شامل يضمن جميع السودانيين ندعو
القوى المدنيه والديمقراطيه الحقيقيه
وقادتها الذين اثبتوا انهم مع انهاء الحرب
وبناء الدوله الجديده القائمه على انقاذ
الحقبه الاستعماريه الوطنيه القديمه نتخذ
خطوات جديه من اجل الانخراط في حوار ين
ينهي الحرب ويقود الى تشكيل حكومه تلبي
طموحات الشعب سوف يكون الطريق هذه المره
معبد لبناء دوله سودانيه جديده خاليه من
هيمنه النخب ومخططاتهم ومقد المعروفه
لافشال كل خطوه نحو التحول الى نظام سياسي
ودستوري جديد في السودان المواطنون
الاعزاء نحن في قياده قوات الدعم السريع
نعبر عن بالق وعميق افنا وحزننا لاهلنا
المطيبين على الانتهاكات الواسعه التي
وقعت بحقهم خاصه في ولايه
الجزيره لقد بذلنا في الايام القليله
الماضيه يهودا مكثفه ومتواصله من اجل
السيطره على المتفلتين وهم لا علاقه لهم
بالدعم السريع وسوف نستمر في ذلك من منطلق
مسؤوليتنا الوطنيه والاخلاقيه المتفلتين
هم عدو لنا تماما كالعدو الذي نحاربه منذ
ال عشر من ابريل كما سيطرنا عليهم في
ولايه دارفور التي تنعم الان بالامان
والاستقرار سوف نسيطر عليهم في ولايه
الجزيره ونحاسبهم ردعا لهم وتحقيقا
للعداله الناجزه عبر المحاكم والتدابير
الاداريه واللازمه انني اجدد اليوم بهذا
الخصوص وامرنا وتعليمات المستديمه لكل
قواتنا في مدينه مدني والجزيره بحمايه
المواطنين وتامين الممتلكات العامه
والخاصه ونادينا القصف العشوائي بالطيران
وقتل المدنيين ومجره نياله ليس
ببعيد